hello guys I'm Ryan Wright today we're
going to check out the trailer Suicide
Squad official trailer number one even
though we got the comic-con trailer
already now we got the official trailer
I'm excited for this movie I have a lot
of anticipation thoughts that I want to
share I'll share them more after this
trailer is shown to me so let's just
watch this first and then I'll give you
my immediate thoughts this is just
fantasy we get from reality I want a
simple task force it the most dangerous
people on the planet they're bad guys
worst of the worst
what this cheerleading tryouts
huh Deadshot shoots people he's cracking
out he eats people burns people you're
possessed by Twix and she's just crazy
oh we're back I should kill everyone in
this gate sorry
the voices I'm kidding is that what they
really said this is the deal you're
going somewhere very bad do something
don't gets chilled so save the world I
can't wait to show you my toys
let's do something fun
me
seriously doc hell's wrong with you
people
you're bad guys that's what we do
you can't help but worry about some
things but overall that was a pretty
cool trailer you know like I hope this
movie is as crazy and manic as this
trailer is trying to make it out to be I
was expecting more of like that dramatic
take kind of like the comic-con trailer
did this one was kind of showing the
madness behind all this I would like
that you know how like I don't want it
to be like Mad Max fury road but you
know how Mad Max fury road had that
mania to it and that I would like to see
that because ooh these are the villains
you know you got Margot Robbie as Harley
Quinn and I seen the whole Batman the
Animated Series I love that show one of
my all-time favorite shows and honestly
it's probably the best depiction of
Batman we've gotten so far in terms of
like film and TV combined and Harley
Quinn I love her loved Harley Quinn what
I liked about this trailer was that
actually showed us it's going to be like
several moments between her and the
Joker you know because the comic-con
trailer it is kind of make it look like
the Joker is sometimes in the movie and
I know they're still keeping him a
little bit secret here they don't want
him to steal the whole show exactly did
the marketing at least but that was the
big thing with Harley Quinn was I was
excited for Harley Quinn to be in this
but I feel like we're really gonna get
that sense of Harley Quinn in love with
the Joker I want to see more of those
scenes that I find that that might be
the most intriguing part if executed
well and Will Smith is dead shot you
know like I like his portrayal so far
cause it's so depressed and there's like
an emptiness to him cuz you know it's
Deadshot you know he has a death wish
like he ain't suicidal but he really
could care less about living and I could
see Will Smith doing that and he is like
one of the most vital members of the
Suicide Squad and I don't have a problem
with portraying the good inside of bad
guys but something that
worries me I've only seen footage from
trailer I'm sure it'll be a different
experience when I'm actually watching
the movie but it is the fact that it's
Will Smith as Deadshot because Will
Smith he's so charismatic likeable
superstar that I'm wondering if I'll
have be able to just buy him more as
this villainous role who has a heart as
well you know rather than it's just Will
Smith playing another hero of the movie
and going back to that manic vibe I feel
like you do need that because they have
characters in the Suicide Squad that are
clearly out of something that's
fictional you know sci-fi or
supernatural like you got enchantress in
here who is a witch and she would like
manipulates energy she'd walk through
walls and you got Killer Croc who is
just the brute force he's not the most
intellectual dude but he's a violent
force and focusing on the villains
specifically you got a character like
Killer Croc who is violent as [ __ ] and I
can't remember I think this movie is
most likely going to be pg-13 but if it
was rated R I'd probably be more excited
for it because they're taking these
villains and they're probably going to
commit to the level of violence if it's
pg-13 that might detract a little bit
for me because there's all this gunfire
and stuff but then it kind of distracts
me when there's all that but you're like
where's all the blood and everything I
gotta say man I do Jai Courtney a lot of
[ __ ] like I have talked so much [ __ ] on
Jai Courtney this trailer
he is really intriguing me to see his
performance he looks really committed to
it he looks like he's giving a
performance with emotion instead of just
being kind of dead on the inside I like
what I'm seeing from the guy and I you
know as Captain boomerangs that's gonna
be pretty cool I want to see his
boomerang and effect you know and
boomerang swing you know stuff like
really kill someone you could slice
someone's like head off or something
with a boomerang I want to get some of
that like gore in there okay look I'll
settle for this if it's pg-13 that's
fine I get it
kalanick books got a feel to the masses
and all that [ __ ] but make like a
unrated version for the DVD I'm telling
you it'll do well they did show teases
of like Killer Croc the witch but the
characters are the really showcase in
the marketing is primarily like the real
human people you know
Harley Quinn Deadshot Captain Boomerang
I know people are gonna want me to
comment on the Joker I really don't have
much to say here about the joke I mean
like whatever the [ __ ] he said in this
trailer I'm sure is gonna be the next
big quote from the Joker yeah he looks
like he's doing a cool job I like that
they're not giving you a definition of
ears how different it is cuz I feel like
that'll actually be a nice surprise when
I actually watch the film one slight
thing I'm picking up on with Jared
Leto's Joker Heath Ledger's was like a
criminal mastermind who he was insane
but he was a genius here I'm getting a
more insane vibe like this Joker seems
batshit insane bat [ __ ] insane like
there's that one shot where it has all
those weapons laid out around him he's
just laughing maniacally like that's not
to say that this Joker is gonna be you
know a dumbass I just feel like this
one's gonna be a little bit more insane
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to the
channel if you're new to it you can
subscribe today by becoming a reject you
can follow us on our social networks
specifically vine and Instagram I am
using primarily those two and I'm having
a blast with them
Joshua Knoll just watched the Rhine and
Tyrone Skype video and I have to say it
was eye-opening made you see more human
thanks as ridiculous as that sounds
excellent channel keep up the rate
videos all you thanks Joshua no Joshua
no you know what my friend that is not
dull it is your penis your penis makes
you quite the genius
I go around here and I get a little
delirious as I think about Joshua
Knowles non dull penis you know what
that's let's get enough that's your shut
up